Is wack. Yeah. Bella tour.
What is a ballad tour? I
have no idea. I have no idea,
but I'm,
I feel like you can kind of feel the
difference in their promotion when you go,
they're getting bigger and bigger.
Right.
But you can feel a difference
when you're there of course.
But you see the talent that's an
then you're like, oh shit. You know,
and they got goldy over there now.
I Ms. Golden Oldies.
I saw him when I was there. He's
always, always puts a smile on my face.
I love energy. I miss him. I love Jon
Anik too though, you know, and, and um,
you know, I just think they just don't
have the funds that the UFC has. Yeah.
It's just,
they don't have the deep pockets or the
UFC and the UFC has been around for so
long. They just know how to do it.
They've just made the right moves.
And we looked, there were these p and man,
that's so crazy. Amazing. I'm so awesome.
When that was signed,
I was so pumped just to see what it's
going to be in five years when been
fingers with ESPN,
like how much we're going to be
on TV and the shows they're doing.
They're doing this thing to that.
It's like a,
not only are they going to fall the
winter around after their fight,
they're also gonna follow the loser around
to get into your life. I mean, yeah,
it's going to fucking suck.
You think about it. It's like,
I don't want a camera follow
me around a fire hose,
but they want to see how it affects
your life. Like, like me, I've been,
I mean obviously I've been pretty pissed
off about it, you know? Right. Like me,
if I wasn't staying busy with
my businesses and my family,
like I would lose my mind. You
know, like I would like to see that.
Like say Brian Ortega after
he fought Max Holloway,
he goes into that fight looking on
beatable and gets just, just touched up,
you know,
Max Holloway just touched them up.
We really got to see who the fuck
Max Holloway is after that fight.
And his distance control and
just pace and output everything.
He's just a champion. He's just a
fucking champion. His mindset down. Yeah.
He's just a champion. Gangsters,
gangsters. They caught me. I love it.
He's so gangster or tag is as tough as
they come to him and he just wasn't ready
for that yet. I think he will be
man. Like he's was saying like that.
Like I have a camera
phone around after loss.
Like I think he's looking for new things
now too. That's what I mean. If you're,
if you're a guy that takes a loss and
you don't branch out to do new things,
you're never going to get better.
Well his Jujitsu is off the charts.
When he grabbed a hold out co cubs neck
when he got the Doris at the end of the
first round was like, Holy
Shit, it's over. Yeah.
But the bell rang and he got out of it,
but then the sac around when he jumped
on him and grabbed that key guillotine,
he went over the top of him like other
extended up in a clinch and got it and
then came down on it. And then
had it in the air. It's nasty.
His technique is so fucking sharp.
And he could do that with everything.
I mean armbars trying, he's got like
a good squeeze cardio too. Oh yeah.
Well you know what, he's,
he's real legacy Jujitsu.
He comes from,
you know that Henner and here on camp and
you know from that's Horian school and
were hoist was from, that's the
torrents crew. I mean that's,
that's right from the fucking
motherland. But that is, and you know,
there's a term that some people get
offended by that term is basic Jujitsu.
I'm not offended by that at all because
some of the very best guys of all time,
whether it's hodge,
Gracie or Hixon,
you don't see them doing like weird stuff.
It's all very standard.
It's not, I mean there's basic striking
yeah. At Max Holloway beat or take it,
he was basic striking to beat
him. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
I mean basics win national titles
and wrestling 100% a high crotch,
100% you know, a sprawling stand behind.
But it's the level of the basics.
And this is what I was going to
say about Max Hallways Jujitsu.
It's like the level of his basics.
He's just,
it's so fucking polished.
It's like as a,
as a person who loves martial arts,
for me,
when I see someone who's technique
is that sharp, I'm like, whoa.
That's what I want to tell people.
This is why I get frustrated.
When I see people that are on their
back and they're in the open guard,
there are,
their legs are just kind of sitting
there flailing away and the guy's got his
arms on the ground. I'm like, Jesus
Christ, he's, he's giving arm bars.
He's giving you all my plots
as he's giving you a sweep.
He's setting himself up and
people don't know what to do.